Venezuelans rally against dictator
nicolas maduro president Trump caves on
the State of the Union and the mega hot
Wars continue i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show many things to get
to you today we're gonna get into the
latest on Venezuela because it is
interesting how certain people certain
fresh faces aren't being asked serious
questions about the situation in
Venezuela we'll get to that in just one
second first let me remind you that
there is no reason that you need to live
with an enormous amount of credit card
debt for years credit card companies
have basically been telling you yeah I
live off the debt that's totally fine
and then it turns out that you're
getting in sorbets and interest rates
you've racked up these enormous charges
it's gonna take you decades to pay off
know more with Lending Club you can
consolidate your debt or pay off credit
cards with one fixed monthly payment
since 2007 Lending Club has helped
millions of people regain control of
their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to a
bank no high interest credit cards just
go to Lending Club com tell them about
yourself how much you want to borrow
pick the terms that are right for you if
you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
accounts in as little as a few days
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion dollars in loans issued go to
Lending Club comm slash Ben check their
rate in minutes borrow up to 40 grand
that is Lending Club comm slash Ben
again Lending Club com
slash Ben all loans made by web bank
member FDIC Equal Housing lender again
that's Lending Club com slash Ben
there's no reason for you to be living
on that credit card debt instead
consolidate your financial house in
order
Lending Club com / Ben go check them out
right now let them know that we sent you
alrighty so the big news of the day is
not the State of the Union it's not the
government shutdown it's what's
happening in Venezuela literally
hundreds of thousands of people marching
on the streets of Venezuela it's
astonishing I mean that the pictures are
just incredible here's a picture from
Caracas Venezuela the capital where
hundreds of thousands of people poured
into the streets in opposition to the
evil dictator of Venezuela Nicolas
Maduro Maduro you'll recall took office
after the death of Google Chavez was
also an evil dictator for a long time
the left love them from Hugo Chavez they
thought the Chavez was just wonderful
because Chavez used the oil wealth of
the country to even out income
inequality he was one who had cured
poverty
hidden what he's going to had cured the
health care system in Venezuela well now
people there are eating dogs because it
turns out that when a bad person gets in
charge of a top-down centralized
government system they wrecked the
country and that happened with ago
Chavez and now it's happening with
Nicolas Maduro here's what some of the
footage looked like from Caracas
Venezuela I mean this footage is
astonishing you can't see the number of
people I mean I was just at a I was just
at a rally last Friday with probably
half a million people this is bigger
than that
people cheering and holding the
Venezuelan flag the United States has
recognized Nicolas maduro's
opposition a guy named Quan Guido as
interim president on Wednesday leaving
Nicolas Maduro ever more isolated as he
faces unrest at home and threats from
the United States according to Reuters
long-standing leftist allies Bolivia and
Cuba are now the only countries in the
region to explicitly voice support for
Maduro as Argentina Brazil Chile
Colombia Costa Rica Ecuador Guatemala
Honduras Panama Paraguay and Peru have
all backed Cueto the United States and
Canada have also recognized quite oh the
35 year-old leader of Venezuela's
opposition nam dominated national
assembly as Venezuela is legitimate
ruler Mexico struck a discordant note
because the leftist president their
president the ominous Manuel Lopez
Obrador
said it would not take size and they
branded sides and they branded support
from white or a violation of sovereignty
okay so this is breaking down really
along two lines one is the line that
says no Maduro should stay in power
and they should negotiate a settlement
and the other is Maduro needs to go and
most of the Western world has taken the
position that Maduro needs to go your
friendly Democratic socialists have
decided at least in part no you know
what
Maduro should stay never mind that he's
an evil piece of crap I mean like a
legitimate evil piece of human debris
it's amazing
yeah I'll explain me in a second how
amazing it is that there are folks
coming out in quasi support for for
Maduro and make no mistake when you have
hundreds of thousands of people who are
marching to oppose a military
dictatorship instituted from above and
folks are saying oh we should have
negotiated settlement it's pretty clear
which camp they are in Reuters says the
telegenic widow declared himself
Venezuela's temporary President on
Wednesday at a rally that drew hundreds
of thousands of Venezuelans he accused
Maduro of usurping power and promised to
create a transitional government the
diplomatic
support for wydo was a striking move in
a region where countries tend to refrain
from criticizing each other despite
their political differences criticism of
Maduro has grown in recent years as his
government has sidelined the National
Assembly held widely questioned
elections and overseen an economic
crisis that has forced millions of
Venezuelans to flee mostly to other
South American countries at the same
time because of all of this right
leading governments in South America
have risen to power in places like
Brazil because the fact is you can only
run on somebody else's money for so long
the same thing has happened in Argentina
president Trump has reiterated that all
options are on the table his
administration signaled potential new
sanctions against Venezuela 'he's vital
oil sector so who is opposing the move
to get rid of Maduro well you got Russia
so Vladimir Putin is coming out against
this move in Venezuela so Russia is
saying that the United States should not
intervene militarily in Venezuela by the
way nobody's talked about military
military intervention in Venezuela as of
yet and nobody is really seriously
discussing that we're talking about new
economic sanctions at this point and
again providing whatever resources to
the opposition are necessary that's not
really a military intervention
Venezuelan opposition leader Hwang wydo
declared himself interim president on
Wednesday as we have said violence has
flared during big protests across
Venezuela when they mean violence is
flared what they mean is that Maduro x'
forces are now attacking the protesters
in an interview with russian journal
international affairs published on
Thursday Deputy Foreign Minister Sergei
Ryabkov said Moscow would stand with
Venezuela to protect its sovereignty and
the principle of non-interference in its
domestic affairs weird weird that Russia
would do that because I seem to recall
Russia invading a sovereign neighbor
specifically on the basis that their
domestic affairs were not properly in
order Russia invaded Crimea and they
also invaded Georgia on specifically
this basis so in other words Russia is
completely full of it as per their usual
arrangement asked about the prospects of
US military intervention in Venezuela
the OPCON said Washington should steer
clear as well so we warned against that
we consider that would be a catastrophic
scenario that would shake the
foundations of the development model
which we see in Latin America there is
no development model in Venezuela the
development model in Venezuela is to
grab all the resources centralize them
in Nicolas Maduro pass them out to his
friends supporters and military allies
and destroy the people of Venezuela that
is his program it has always been his
as the program of Hugo Chavez as well
when it turned out that centralizing
resources and his populist top-down
government was going to fail when it
became clear that you can't just make a
country prosperous by grabbing all its
wealth and redistributing it Hugo Chavez
simply started paying off all of his
political allies to keep himself in
power and this has been true for
legitimately years now what's amazing
about this is that you would assume that
some of the folks who are sort of
friendly toward the majority Minh the
United States some folks in the
Democratic Party would be asked about
such things you might assume that
Michael Moore who has come out in favor
of Hugo Chavez years ago would be asked
about such things like I think for
example it might be worthwhile to ask
Alexandre Ocasio Cortez the fresh face
of the Democratic Party about this thing
while she was a member of the Democratic
socialists of America until the last
five minutes she was a member I believe
of the GSA as of May 2016 when they
called on President Obama in the US
Congress to end unjust sanctions against
Venezuela quote this kind of dishonest
and cynical behavior is an embarrassment
to all good people in the United States
for DSA a group of activists committed
to fighting for socialism and democracy
in the US and around the world
it is especially repulsive we therefore
state our solidarity with the people of
Venezuela and call on our own government
to stop its illegal
unjust interference with Venezuela
specifically to repeal these terrible
laws that reverse this dishonest
executive order so they're ripping on
Obama for being too harsh on Venezuela
the DSA while AOC was purportedly a
member and so we're sort of all waiting
with with bated breath what would a OC
say about all of this
especially since nobody's asking her
nobody the media seems it's appropriate
to ask so this morning just in the last
few minutes she has tweeted out she
retweeted something from a guy named
roll Khanna roll Khanna is a Obama
commerce alum that's what he calls
himself
and here is what Roe Cano tweeted with
respect to Senator Durbin senator dick
durbin came out in favor of Maduro
saponin Roe Cano tweeted with respect to
Senator Durbin the US should not anoint
the leader of the Opposition in
Venezuela during an internal polarized
conflict let us support Uruguay Mexico
and the Vatican's efforts for a
negotiated settlement and end sanctions
that are making the hyperinflation worse
in other words
he is coming out in favor of the Maduro
regime I mean that's what that is if you
are coming out in favor of a negotiated
settlement that removes sanctions and
leaves Maduro in power then you are
coming out in favor of the Maduro regime
alexandra Ocasio cortez her only comment
so far has been to retweet that now when
I point that out there a bunch of folks
on the Left who say well that's taking
her out of context no that's that's the
whole context I read in the entire tweet
and she retweeted it take that for what
it's worth I think there's only one way
to interpret that and that is as
undercutting the Democratic opposition
in Venezuela because right now is the
time to move right now is not the time
to say oh well y'know negotiated
settlement Maduro has a point and said
we can't interfere let's remove the
sanctions weird that she and Russia have
the exact same position on this very odd
isn't it very strange and this is the
same thing you hear from the left one
when a OC is parlaying with all the
folks who want to boycott Israel and
then folks on left us
and folks on the left hand I don't know
she doesn't support boycott of Israel
just hangs out with all those folks and
forwards their agenda okay how about a
straight question that she is forced to
answer by the media asked repeatedly do
you think Nicolas Maduro must go now
like it's it is straight easy question
will she be asked that question maybe
she should be asked like what did he do
wrong like you're an economics expert
supposedly so what did he do wrong
what did Marissa row do Robert Venezuela
really get screwed up what did they do
wrong but nobody on the Left will be
asked these questions despite longtime
support for Hugo Chavez on the populist
left remember Oliver Stone traveling
down to do a movie about Julio Chavez
and his greatness it's also worthwhile
remembering that Venezuela's government
is just one of the most evil governments
on planet earth so this notion that
you're supposed to negotiate with
Nicolas Maduro
and you're supposed to undercut the
protesters by not recognizing the
National Assembly led opposition is
insane Amnesty International a left-wing
outfit if ever there was one Amnesty
International says that the Venezuelan
government is responsible for the worst
human crisis in human rights crisis in
its history as days of September the
organization claimed that several human
rights abuses
had taken place in the South American
country including the use of lethal
force against the most vulnerable in its
society it said that eight thousand two
hundred and ninety-two extra
executions had taken place between 2015
and 2017 so over 8,000 murders of people
who didn't agree with the regime between
2015 and 2017 it found that 22% of all
homicides in 2016 were at the hands of
security officials it found that the
economic economic insecurity in the
country we're at 87 percent 87 percent
of Venezuelans were living in abject
poverty there was a 65% increase in
maternal mortality and a 30% increase in
infant mortality Venezuelan authorities
have publicly stated that killing people
in the context of security operations is
a successful practice since 2014 2.3
million people have fled Venezuela but
don't worry ALC thinks a negotiated
settlement with Maduro is gonna do the
trick yeah but it has nothing to do with
her support for for Venezuela democratic
socialism not nothing I'll get some more
of this in a second first let me remind
you you want to make your business
better this year well why would you
overspend on legal costs okay the fact
is you can spend literally hundreds of
thousands of dollars on legal costs but
there's no reason for you to do it
instead go check out Legal Zoom right
now with their network of independent
attorneys licensed in all 50 states
Legal Zoom can help you navigate your
legal needs from wills and trusts to
LLC's trademarks contract reviews and
more Legal Zoom has helped more than 4
million people like you take care of
their responsibilities the best part is
Legal Zoom is not a law firm so you
won't get charged by the our lawyers use
Legal Zoom for a lot of that forms but
now you get even more than just the
forms over at Legal Zoom I've been using
it for years now you have that network
of licensed attorneys so make this the
year you finally do the right thing for
your business and don't waste money with
lawyers you don't need start writing
your 20-19 story at legalzoom.com right
now for special savings be sure to enter
promo code been in the referral box at
check out Legal Zoom is indeed where
life meets legal that is legalzoom.com
and again when you enter promo code been
at checkout in the referral box then you
will get special savings so go check
them out right now legalzoom.com make
sure that you are saving on your legal
services the way that you should
venezuela is indeed a terribly run
country and here's the reality it's been
a terribly run country for years i know
that the left wants to suggest that this
is just since Chavez died or the late
years of ago Chavez it's been terribly
run since the late 90s when Lugo
Travis's government decided to
nationalize all of the oil industry
redistribute the wealth put the gut
that company in the hands of his best
friends in the government centralize all
power move all the dissenters out of the
military if you take a look at Chavez
his record you see people on the Left
praising him for reducing poverty in
Latin America hey that is really not the
case the fact is the poverty across
Latin America reduced during the 1990s
and 2000s because of economic growth it
kind of was equivalent in Venezuela
about the same but Chavez destroyed the
economy I mean just destroyed it because
he made the entire economy dependent on
oil the entire economy dependence on the
government's exports of oil so when the
oil prices dropped the economy just fell
apart fell apart so here are a few ways
that Chavez destroyed the economy and
Maduro has followed suit is from Steven
Keppel over at ABC News number one
Venezuela went from being heavily
dependent on oil in 1998 seventy-seven
percent to Venezuela as exports in 1998
were oil by 2011 oil was 96 percent of
all exports that's because of the
idiotic Marxist notion known as
dependency theory dependency theory is
this idea that if you are a if you are a
state like Venezuela you're a country
like Venezuela and you are importing
goods you are dependent on those goods
you have been made dependent so you have
to raise tariffs to extraordinary levels
so that you can create homegrown
industry the only problem is your
consumers can't afford any of that stuff
and so you end up impoverishing your
country the only thing Venezuela was
exporting the only thing was oil so when
the oil prices dropped catastrophe the
Chavez government crippled private
businesses and national industry through
expropriations and nationalizations they
expropriated or nationalized various
sectors including aluminum cement gold
iron steel farming transportation
electricity food production banking
paper and the media the number of
private companies and industry dropped
from 14,000 in 1998 to 9,000 and 2011 no
one in their right mind would build a
factory in Venezuela because it was
going to be nationalized expropriated
and stolen by the government of
Venezuela no-one was investing in 2011
Latin America enjoyed a record of more
than a hundred and fifty billion dollars
in foreign investment with Brazil
receiving 67 billion Venezuela is
neighbor Colombia received 13 billion
Venezuela a country rich in natural
resources and human labour receives only
five billion dollars the Venezuelan
currency has been a mess because it
turns out that when you borrow enormous
quantities of money in order for you to
pay off all of your friends and
supporters well somebody is going to
want that money back and then you have
to inflate your way out of it the bow of
our fuerte was he had lost 2/3 of its
value since it was launched in 2008 it
was launched in 2008 because of a
previous devaluation of the currency
prices in Venezuela went up by 23
percent per year for more than ten years
as of 2011 hey imagine right now in the
United States we have a we have an
inflation rate in prices of maybe 2 3%
per year on average imagine that
everything you buy went up 20% every
year so within five years the price of
everything had doubled hey that's what
was going on in Venezuela and of course
Venezuela become unbelievably violent
because not only were there local police
forces and extrajudicial gangs supported
by the government killing people but
they weren't policing actual crime the
murder rate per 100,000 citizens went
from 25 in 1999 to 45 in 2011 I mean
that's incredible in the same period of
time violence has dropped pretty much
everywhere else on the planet but not in
Venezuela so when you hear the left was
defending Venezuela for years on end I
mean really defending them and then now
it's collapsing I feel like we should go
back and we should have to ask all these
folks who defended Venezuela why we
should let them run the American economy
we should have to ask folks like AOC
what her perspective is on Venezuela why
does she think Venezuela failed and if
she says well I'm not an expert on
Venezuela and say well read a book lady
how about you actually like that's fine
you don't have to be an expert on
Venezuela how about you do some reading
and come back to us and say a week how
about that but the notion here is that
if you're on the left and you support a
radical regime that is socialistic in
nature and then it fails you have
nothing to apologize for
and this has been the crucial the most
crucial aspect of the left's continuing
momentum for the last hundred years is
that they never have to apologize for
supporting regimes that end in failure
tragedy and human destruction the left
was heavily supportive of the USSR in
the 1920s and 1930s even as millions of
people were being slaughtered the left
in America
heavily supportive of Cuba when when
Castro took power he was loud at by the
media
he's an American tour che guevara was
featured on a bunch of top-line news
networks as a revolutionary leader
there's still college students wearing
around Che Guevara t-shirts today hey he
was an evil mass murderer Cuba is a
human gulag it's all after a little
while this stuff becomes uncomfortable
for the left and then they move on to
the next country now they'll have their
country of the future of Venezuela
during the 90s in the early 2000s was
the country of the future well now it's
the country of the past and it's
interesting to see how folks on the Left
are reacting to all of this again if you
are satisfied if you are satisfied with
a o'seas answer on all of this let me
suggest that you and the media you
firefighters are not doing your jobs
which is just a massive shock I know I
know I'm shocked that you're not doing
your jobs I'm shocked that you're not
going and asking Bernie Sanders about
Venezuela and his perspective on Maduro
now a lot of these folks on the hard
left are going to hide behind
non-interventionism and we can't get
involved guys we really can't get
involved same people will argue by the
way that the State of Israel should be
boycotted because the State of Israel is
mean even though the State of Israel is
more liberal than any of the countries
that they have supported in terms of
human rights in terms of accepting other
people in terms of economic freedom but
the same you can't interfere
Venezuela's business as Venezuela's
business well it was that same
perspective that has led to the
continuation of the Iranian regime again
no one is suggested so what net I'll
tell you where the next move is gonna be
now the left is gonna say are you
suggesting war in Venezuela the answer
is no we're suggesting a continuation of
exactly the same policies that have
brought hundreds of thousands of people
into the street with massive public
support to depose one of the worst
regimes on the planet and if you don't
support that if you think the solution
to this is to leave Maduro in power and
to undercut those protesters I don't
know to tell you because let me tell you
what the next step is if there is a
negotiated settlement and material is
left in power and the military which is
run by Maduro is left in power the next
thing that will happen is the world will
turn its eyes away and then a bunch of
people will get slaughtered
because that is exactly the same thing
that has happened in Turkey in Turkey
there's an attempt to failed coup
attempt against air Dewan who's in Islam
dictator it happened what a year ago now
there are those of us were rooting hard
for air Toulon to go he did not go the
West turned a blind eye he proceeded to
jail or murder tens to hundreds of
thousands of people it's a no one cares
now he's part of the community of
nations again hey the only way to fight
dictatorship is to keep your eye on it
all the time and to condemn it and to
call for its owl sting there cannot be
deals made with evil dictators who are
running roughshod over their own people
to keep those dictators in power
especially when those dictators are not
allies of the United States many when it
comes down to American interest there's
no question America's interests lie in
Majuro going all right in just a second
I'm going to talk about the State of the
Union address and president Trump caving
on that we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about your
online security and privacy so as a
public figure I'm constantly worried
about being hacked or spied on I don't
want my emails compromised or my credit
card number or online banking passwords
stolen but that does happen to hundreds
of millions of people every single year
so how can you protect yourself well the
company I trust to defend my online
security and privacy is expressvpn
expressvpn secures and anonymizes my
connection by encrypting 100% of my
network data and hiding my IP address
that means nobody can record or access
of my online activity download the
Express VPN app on your computer or
smartphone and then just use the
internet the way you normally would you
click one button in the expressvpn app
and voila you are now protected
expressvpn is great for accessing
content from anywhere with VPN locations
in 94 countries and blazing fast speeds
expressvpn has consistently rated the
world's number-one VPN service for
Internet users so if you wanna protect
yourself online which you should I mean
there's nothing worse than having your
identity hacked your credit cards stolen
the nice folks at expressvpn have
extended special pricing of less than
seven bucks per month to all my fans so
go visit expressvpn comm slash ben and
go claim that discount again that is
expressvpn comm slash Ben's to learn
more expressvpn comm slash penn go check
it out right now okay meanwhile
president from unfortunately just caved
when it came to the State of the Union
address so as you recall there was a
showdown between the President and Nancy
Pelosi to Nancy Pelosi issued an
invitation for the president to deliver
the State of the Union address and then
she revoked that invitation saying that
there
there were no security resources
available which of course was a lie and
then President Trump said well maybe
I'll just do something else for the
State of the Union address maybe I'll go
over to the Senate chamber and give the
State of the Union address from there or
maybe I'll go down to the border maybe
I'll count for program the State of the
Union address well now president Trump
has basically caved he says as the
shutdown was going on he just tweeted
this out as the shutdown was going on
Nancy Pelosi asked me to give the State
of the Union address I agreed she then
changed her mind because of the shutdown
suggesting a later date this is her
prerogative I will do the address when
the shutdown is over I am NOT looking
for an alternative venue for the State
of the Union address because there is no
venue that can compete with the history
tradition and importance of the House
chamber I look forward to giving a great
State of the Union address in the near
future okay so what that means is that
if he caves and then has to give a State
of the Union address after caving to
Democrats it's gonna be humiliating for
him so either it means he's doubling
down on his position with regard to the
government shutdown or it means that the
government shutdown ends ignominiously
with him taking some sort of executive
action to redirect funds from one area
to another area whatever it is not a
great look for the president as I
suggested he should have counter
programmed this thing he should have
simply said okay well you know you don't
want to have me to the Congress because
you don't want me pointing directly at
you and saying that this is your fault
Nancy Pelosi well instead I'm just gonna
go down to the border and I'm going to
say that this is your fault because in
fact it is your fault the President of
the United States has come out with
several proposals for changing the math
here but those proposals have been met
with complete complete apathy and
indifference by the Democratic Party now
as the shutdown continues things are in
fact getting worse and worse you know in
the early days of a shutdown the good
lesson to be learned is that a lot of
the essential services that we the
non-essential services that we think we
can't live without we can actually live
without but as the shutdown continues an
essential personnel you know folks in
the TSA folks in the Department of
Defense as those folks Department of
Homeland Security don't get their checks
then things get ugly very quickly air
controllers air traffic controllers
they're saying listen we got a lot of
folks retiring and those folks have no
interest in staying employed if they're
not gonna get paid so we may be in fact
understaffed and the president can't
simply order new hires when there's no
money coming into the federal government
and no spending taking place on the
federal government
level so things are gonna get worse and
worse
folks are in fact showing up you know in
in at food at food lines because they
don't actually have money because
they're not getting their checks so
let's not pretend that the government
shutdown isn't a bad thing it is a bad
thing is this is not how the government
is supposed to operate but the answer to
that is Nancy Pelosi signing a minut
check for some borders for some border
fencing that's all
which again assess it Tate's the
president getting on his horse and going
around the country telling Americans why
exactly the government is currently shut
down right now Democrats have come up
with a counter so according to the
Associated Press House Democrats feeling
pressure to display their vision for
border security are preparing a package
that would ignore president Trump's
demand for 5.7 billion dollars for a
wall with Mexico and would instead pay
for other areas aimed at protecting the
border again this shows how petty they
are because they're willing to spend a
bunch of money on border security but
not on the fencing as I said before I
think the solution to the government
shutdown is pretty easy that is
President Trump should say listen I know
you guys hate me I know that you guys
don't want to give me a victory and I
know that you're pretending that we
don't need a border fence because you
think that I'm doing something deeply
wrong because I am Trump but here's an
idea
I won't even intervene I want you to
delegate five billion dollars to border
security to be allotted as the people in
border control see fit we'll let an
impartial panel of border control
specialists who work for border control
work for ice and who work for the in who
work for immigration naturalization we
will let all the Border Patrol agents
decide where the money goes so it's not
up to me it's not me saying I need the
wall its Border Patrol deciding where
the money goes and then Democrats can
say okay we didn't give him his wall we
gave the money to Border Patrol for them
to use it where they best see fit and
then if it turns out it's a wall Trump
gets his win and Democrats can say we
didn't give him the win Border Patrol
given the win right in essence kick all
the responsibility over to Border Patrol
that seems like not a terrible idea to
me Democrats are instead saying sure
we'll do border security but we won't
give Trump anything that he wants as the
government slog through a record 33rd
day of its partial shutdown on Wednesday
details of Democrats border security
plan and its costs remain to work in
progress according to the AP though some
said it might match Trump's 5.7 billion
dollar
party leader said it would include money
for scanning devices and other
technological tools for improving
security at ports of entry and along the
boundary plus funds for more border
agents and immigration judges if his 5.7
billion dollars is about border security
then we see ourselves fulfilling that
request only doing it with what I like
to call using a smart wall said number
three House Democratic Leader Jim
Clyburn Democrat of South Carolina again
listen I don't know that Trump is a
border expert I certainly know that
House Democrats are not border experts
because they haven't really cared very
deeply about border security for quite a
while so again the solution kick it over
to the regulators I mean we it's
hilarious we have now found the one area
of American government where legislators
don't want to kick the responsibility
over to the regulators so the
Legislature will constantly pass bills
saying you know what EPA you write all
the regulations we'll send you some
funding and you fill in all the blanks
we'll send you a legislation that looks
like mad libs it says here's a billion
dollars for blank and you just fill in
what you think you need we'll do that
with the Department of Education we'll
do that with the Department of Health
and Human Services we'll do with every
executive department when it comes to
border patrol then the Democrats are
like you know what we know this stuff we
know this down to the down to the marrow
so we're gonna specifically determine
where that money goes or is it just a
cynical ploy the answer of course is
that it is in fact a very cynical ploy
well the shutdown according to polling
data again is hurting President Trump
with the general public just 34% of
Americans like his performance as
president according to this latest
Associated Press poll six in 10 assigned
a great deal of responsibility to him
for the shutdown around double the share
currently playing blaming Democrats
there's a Senate GOP bill that would
temporarily shield from deportation
700,000 dreamers and in return Trump
would get his border security wall
Democrats have objected to other
provisions in that same bill because
they're saying they're poison pills in
there okay again this is where the
negotiations should start but there is
no negotiation that is currently taking
place there are a couple proposals that
have been floated out there I'll get to
those in just one second but first let's
talk about your mobile bill so the big
and big wireless provider stands for a
lot of things big contracts big bills
big fees like AT&T has a new 800 million
dollar administrative fee increase but
what big Wireless doesn't want you to
know is there is a way to cut your
wireless
- just 15 bucks a month this is why you
need mint mobile the game-changing
company that's taken everything wrong
with big Wireless and made it right you
could save like a thousand dollars a
year with mint mobile without
sacrificing quality service how well
mint global makes it really easy use
your own fund phone with any mint mobile
plan you can keep your old number along
with all your existing contacts choose
between 2 5 or 10 gigabyte 4G LTE plans
so the way a lot of these phone
companies get is they say you need
unlimited data and then you don't use
anything like unlimited data and then
they charge you for the unlimited data
well you don't need to do that every
plan comes with unlimited talk and text
if you are not 100% satisfied main
mobile has you covered with their 7 day
money-back guarantees you can try it for
a week and if you don't like it I'll
give you your money back
ditch that old wireless bill start
saving right now with mint mobile to get
your new wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month plus free shipping on your new
mint Mobile SIM card go to mint mobile
comm slash Ben that is mint mobile comm
slash been cut that Wireless bill to 15
bucks a month and get free shipping on
the mint Mobile SIM card mint mobile
comm /ban ok I want to talk about some
of the other proposals for the border
shutdown I also want to talk about the
latest with regard to Covington Catholic
because it turns out that the real issue
here is Magga has Magga hats are
inherently terrible and racist really
well get to all that in just one second
first you're gonna have to go subscribe
$9.99 a month gets you a subscription to
this show it gets you a subscription
Andrew Clavin the show Matt Walsh's show
Michael Moses show all sorts of great
shows and Michael nolza show like all
sorts of great stuff and when you
subscribe you also get two additional
hours of me in the afternoon you know
stressful and painful it is to do those
two hours just ask my producers they
have to sit here with me but we're doing
it all for you so that's why you need to
subscribe $99 a year you get all of that
Plus this the leftist here is hot or
cold tumblr go check it out right now
and you can enjoy those tears which are
flowing freely each and every day here
at the ben shapiro show I'll go check
that out right now also when you
subscribe over at YouTube iTunes you get
access to our some day specials you can
ask me questions and all sorts of great
stuff you know like during the radio
show actually during the breaks in the
radio show if you're alive watching then
you can ask me questions during the
breaks and I'll answer them for you so
all sorts of awesome stuff happening
behind the paywall go check it out right
now we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
all righty so some of the new proposals
that are being floated in order to end
this government shutdown according to
Axios Republican senators including
James Lankford of Oklahoma have
advocated for the a particular idea give
a path to green cards to the 700,000
current daca recipients so it's not just
that they have a three year stay of
execution in terms of their in terms of
the deportation but they actually would
have a path to green card so they could
stay permanently Jared Kushner has been
relating this idea to his colleagues in
the White House nobody thinks that the
Trump current offer is going to pass
seven Democratic senators are needed to
pass any package at this point a
Republican senator involved in the
immigration debate said that Kushner
actually wants to go big but senators
are saying that if you throw green cards
on the table then this falls apart
immediately there not enough senators on
the on the Republican side of the aisle
who are willing to go along with this so
we will see whether this is something
that is actually being pushed it seems
like not which is probably right bottom
line is extra pressure extra pressure
this is where you need the president to
get out there on the campaign trail and
do his job this is honestly the
president has a couple of jobs one is to
govern and the other or to at least
enforce the existing law and the other
is to go out there and make the case to
the American people
Twitter ain't gonna do it Twitter is not
the real world in case people have made
that mistake as of recently already so I
need to give you the latest with regards
to the mega hat wars so it turns out
that this whole Covington Catholic High
School controversy it's a big it's a big
nothing burger not only is it a nothing
burger it turns out the guy at the
center of it this Nathan Phillips guy is
pretty much a con man he's pretty much a
con man who goes around leading random
protests against people and lying about
his Vietnam service he says that he
served in Vietnam he said that he
actually was in country I believe in one
of his interviews he was not he was a
refrigerator repairman enlisted in the
Marines from 1972 to 1976 who also went
AWOL three times and none of that
reported by the mainstream media you
have to get that in the right-wing media
so now here's how the story evolved
basically they said that these kids
surrounded the guy not true they said
that the kids were racist to the guy not
true they said that the high school was
racist not true they said the high
school was sexist not true they said
different high school was racist and
sexist not true they
said the kids from this high school long
ago were racist not true so none of that
was true so what was this really about
because when you remove all the other
factors when you remove the fact that
these kids were not being racist that
they were not mocking the guy without
they were not being violent to the guy
what does this come down to in the end
it's that the Maggie hat is inherently
triggering that if you wear a maggot
then you deserve anything you get the
media can destroy you simply for wearing
a red hat I don't like as somebody who
wears funny hats on a daily basis I am
NOT interested in a country where you
can be targeted based simply on the
message that your hat conveys
particularly when people are taking away
a message that you are not conveying
with the hat right there are certain
hats that convey messages right like my
my yarmulke conveys the fact that I'm an
Orthodox Jew that comes along with a set
of values the Magga hat comes along with
a set of values too but the set of
values that is being conveyed is not
necessarily the set of values that is
being interpreted there is in fact a gap
when it comes to the Magda hat a lot of
people wearing the Maggie hat are saying
a couple of things one I'm conservative
I'm pro-life I support president Trump's
general governance and screw the media
right that's that's usually the
undercurrent to the maggot hat right is
screw the media you guys are terrible
and that's fine because a lot of them
are terrible like okay but the message
that a lot of people take away from the
Maggie hat is the worst things about
President Trump so when so the same
thing happens in a normal conversation
about President Trump if you say I
support President Trump you're
Republican you say I support President
Trump what people on the Left take away
from that is you're a racist sexist
bigoted homophobe now to be fair if you
had said I support George W Bush the
Left would have taken away that your
racist sexist bigoted homophobe because
this is generally many on the left's
take away for being even remotely
right-wing on any issue is that your
this but the mag ahac conveys it in
spades to a lot of people on the left so
here is a CNN commentator explaining the
real reason all this happened is because
the kids were wearing Magga hats and
Magga hats are just like KKK hoods I kid
you not this was a thing set on national
television
forget Donald Trump for a moment and
just think about the symbol of that red
hat when I see the make America great
again hat now Chris I am triggered i'm
so triggered this make America great
again hat is just as maddening and
frustrating and triggering for me
look at as a KKK hood like that is the
type of hair to you that your policies
represent and until we can have common
ground and understanding about that it
that it's that triggering we're gonna
continue to have problems okay his
policies represent KKK policies like
this lady is just saying it straight out
and I think it's telling because what
she's actually saying there is not that
Donald Trump is a KKK member so people
support him because of that she's saying
that his very policies are KKK like so
any Republican who supports his
administration's policies which by and
large have been traditionally
conservative is incipient is basically a
KKK member well it's that sort of
language that leads people to put on the
NAG put on the mag a hat seriously it
makes people well I remember I spoke at
University of Michigan a couple of years
ago it was in the middle of the election
cycle in 2016 as you know I did not vote
for any of the presidential candidates
in 2016
because I thought that election was a
complete bleep show I thought it was
terrible
okay so in the middle of that election
cycle I traveled to University of
Michigan to give a speech and a bunch of
the students in the University of
Michigan College Republicans and young
America's Foundation had gone around
campus and they had written Trump make
America great again slogan on the ground
in chalk a bunch of folks on the Left
had been so triggered by this that they
went around crossing it out complaining
suggesting that it was racist to write
Trump's name on the on the ground so
when I went to University of Michigan I
a non Trump supporter in 2016
went to the chalkboard and wrote Trump
2016 on the chalkboard because you know
what screw you really take a hike son
I'm not interested in your perspective
that everyone who supports Donald Trump
is a racist sexist pig and homophobe but
this is what it comes down to these
Covington kids were wearing the mag ahaa
and therefore they deserved anything
they got which is why the media continue
to treat Nathan Phillips with all sorts
of respect despite the fact that he
deserves none he lied about a bunch of
high school kids for political gain for
himself he lied about his own military
service for years and now we are
supposed to treat him with a continuing
level of respect the students are asked
would you meet with Nathan Phillips the
answer is no I don't meet with
pathological liars who slander me on
national television as beasts thugs and
racists no that's not a thing in a
second I'm going to show you that this
is not in fact a rare argument if it's
not in fact a rare argument that this
that the mag
hat is inherently bad so there's a piece
by NOAA Pearl at ski ok over at NBC News
dot-com and here is what the piece is
titled you ready for this Nick sands man
who I've met by the way very nice kid a
student at Covington Catholic says he
was a silent bystander in viral video
video but his mega hat spoke for him
you wear the Maggie hat means you hate
Native Americans that's just the way it
goes by the way you identify as a Native
American when you're not that means you
love Native Americans apparently
according to according to Elizabeth
Warren's campaign the piece says
aligning oneself openly with Trump's
movements sends an aggressive political
message yeah you know do you know what
it suggests it suggests that maybe you
voted Republican or would like to in the
next election cycle or maybe it suggests
that you're sick of Republicans being
maligned but according to the left it
sends the message that you are all
terrible things to all people so if you
even wear the Hat you deserve all the
things that fall upon you here's what no
abreu Laskey schmuck writes before he
encountered omaha elder nathan phillips
at the lincoln memorial covington high
school student Nick Sandman had already
taken steps to provoke and insult people
of color and insult people of color he'd
put on a mad guy hat so now if you put
on a make America great again hat you
are deliberately provoking and insulting
people of color somebody should tell
Kanye West
salmon's face went viral over the
weekend when footage began circulating
of him and his classmates at the Lincoln
Memorial the moment has become something
of a political Rorschach test that also
raises thorny questions about the way
various perspectives become amplified
and even weaponized on social media
sometimes without the benefit of
important facts context is key this is
something both conservatives and
liberals can agree on well turns out
liberals do not agree on this actually
but in this case that context must
include what the teens were wearing and
what that apparel has come to represent
Sam's men was in Washington DC with his
all-male Catholic school classmates to
participate in the March for Life by the
way there he adds all-male here because
it's their sexist they go to an all-male
Catholic school yeah you're a sexist now
if you go to an all oh I went to an
all-male high school you know why
because we didn't want the guys
associating with the girls that the
girls were protected from the guys
seriously like that that's really why
there are separate boys and girls
classes in religious high schools
because you don't want the kids stopping
that's really what it's about but the
they're rocking it across social media
depicts a smiling Sandman standing
toe-to-toe with Phillips as the latter
beater Drummond sang a traditional
prayer song I love how innocuous that
sounds he walked into a crowd of kids
got up in the kids face with the drum
and banged it in the kid's face but
here's the here's the part that gets
really great Sandman presents himself
and his schoolmates as a political
participants in someone else's protests
we were simply there to meet a bus not
become central players in a media
spectacle he says this is the first time
in my life I've ever encountered any
sort of public protest let alone this
kind of confrontation or demonstration
but this characterization is misleading
Sandman and his classmates were making a
political statement as soon as they wore
their Maggie hats in a public space
aligning oneself with Trump's movement
is an aggressive political statement
it's difficult to believe the students
who after all were in Washington for a
political march were unaware of this
Rebecca Jennings at Fox says teens love
Magga hats because they are
transgressive the hats she says can have
different meanings for different people
that's no doubt true but it's also true
that kids wear trump regalia or invoke
trump's name in order to bully and
insult immigrants Muslims black people
Jews Hispanics or members of any of the
other marginalized groups who Trump
himself regularly attacks or
alternatively they are wearing the mega
hat because you know up or Lansky are a
jerk and they want to show you that they
can wear whatever hat they please
because you're a jerk okay there is
something transgressive about wear on
the mag ahead but what it's really about
is people being sick of being called
deplorable being sick of being called
bad people being sick to being called
anti-semitic and racist and bigots and
sexist and homophobic uhz you disagree
with them that's why Trump won the
nomination that's why he won the
presidency is because he was a giant
middle finger to all of those people and
wearing the Magga hat is a giant middle
finger to all of those people - but
resisting the overreach of the left is
not the same thing as endorsing racism
it's just that this is inane but this
isn't the own honestly this isn't the
only article like this today there's
another article from father Edward Beck
over at CNN megawhatts don't belong on a
Catholic school trip weird you know it I
don't think belongs on a Catholic school
trip meeting with Andrew Cuomo the
governor of New York who is a Catholic
all in favour of murdering babies in the
womb up to points of birth by the way in
port
sidenote New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
came out today he says you know what in
consonance with catholic law and
religious thinking i want to fight the
death penalty so lethal injections
lethal injections for nine month old
babies not for people who murder babies
salad salad call okay first of all if I
were in the Catholic Church I'd be
calling on the Pope to excommunicate
Andrew Cuomo like immediately
but priorities priorities over at CNN
the priority is no megawhatts for
Catholics in a recent tweet of mine that
went viral
I made three simple points about the
now-infamous Covington boys incident in
Washington DC writes father Edward Beck
the boy's acted inappropriately
chaperones should have intervened the
boys should not have been permitted to
wear Magga hats if they were
representing the school I welcome this
opportunity to expound on those comments
and more than the 100 more than the 280
characters that Twitter allows so he
continues and he talks about where were
the where were the chaperones first of
all the chaperones were there for part
of it the kids didn't do anything bad
but here is the part where I'd say any
hats on should have had the school name
or a logo identifying them as
participants in the March for Life event
not a hat with a logo the may suggest
stands is not in accord with the mission
statement of their school the Catholic
Church's pro-life teaching encompasses a
panoply of issues such as abortion
immigration capital punishment the
environment and climate change sex
trafficking and the inequitably
distribution of the world's resources so
in other words you can't wear a maggot
hat to a pro-life event for what has
been practically the most pro-life
administration in recent American
history you can't wear manga hat because
that might that might conflict with
other parts of the pro-life Catholic
message like we have to redistribute
resources weird says the hate mail and
threats I have received since my tweet
and honor appearances about this issue
on CNN and HLN have astounded me suppose
that Christians have said the most
violent unch arrabal things imaginable
it is further indication of the vast
political racial and religious divides
that still exist in our country
well or maybe people just don't like it
I mean first of all nobody should say
bad things to people obviously but maybe
the reason people didn't like your tweet
is because your suggestion is that if
you wear the Hat you're a bad person
again for the left red hat bad orange
man bad that's what all this comes down
to government shutdown is about orange
man bad covington high school is about
red hat bad if your political
universe breaks down into Trump and
Trump is bad and everything else doesn't
matter then you're a simpleton you're a
fool
turns out Trump just a guy in the White
House he is not the avatar of all good
or all evil he is not the avatar of all
conservatism or all mana conservatism if
you're thinking in these simplistic
terms and I suggest you go do some
remedial reading of both the Bible and
basic political texts okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like today so
bono yesterday came out he was Davos and
he was asked about the the new push for
socialism he pointed out guys capitalism
has been kind of helpful
capitalism is is not immoral it's amoral
it requires our instruction capitalism
has taken more people out of poverty
than any other ISM but it is a wild
beast and if not tamed it can chew up a
lot of people along the way okay so
here's the problem with what he's saying
so what he what I like is the pond was
actually defending the free market
system which has created more wealth
than any system in the history of
humanity when he says the capitalism is
amoral that is not true free markets are
inherently moral because free markets
assume at their route that you as an
individual have rights and have duties
free markets assume that you are a
person of Worth and that therefore you
have charge of your own labor you have
charge of your own product you have
charge of how to dispense with that
labor and that product the free market
is about individual freedom that's why
it's free any other form of market is a
way of somebody else telling you what to
do with your labor because other
people's interests Trump your own now
and he says that capitalism can be
avaricious no it's not capitalism that's
avaricious it's not free markets that
are a voracious typically is people who
are perverting the free market by
grabbing government incentives in order
to shut down somebody else the nice
thing about the free market is that over
the long haul of time bad companies go
under bad people who cheat tend to go
under over the long haul with history
because no one wants to do business with
people who have been shown to be
cheaters the amount of turnover in the
market is astonishing but does that mean
that the market will always produce
particularly in the short term
the best people winning no of course it
doesn't mean that of course it doesn't
mean that but neither does socialism
socialism means that the best people
never win it means that the people who
would normally succeed in a free-market
are often condemned to penury because
there's somebody who knows better at the
centralized government level that's the
lesson of Venezuela that's the one we
should keep our eye on ok time for a
couple of things that I hate
all right so Kate Hudson is now doing
the trendy thing I love when we get to
learn how actresses are raising their
children because that's why I would look
to to raise my kids our people who read
lines for other people so Kate Hudson is
embracing a genderless approach when it
comes to raising daughter Rani Rose the
39 year old actress who welcomed her
first child with boyfriend Danny
Fujikawa in October recently opened up
about her parenting style with
three-month-old rani in a new interview
with AOL first of all you can't raise
your kid gender at 30 months old his
kids poop and they vomit and they eat
that's all they do at 30 months old so
I'm not sure what this would involve I
mean really like realistically speaking
you treat a girl baby and a boy baby
exactly the same when they are three
months old except for the manner in
which you wipe their butts legitimately
that's the only difference I'm going to
have a girl I know
okay so I'll also note that there is
something highly irritating about rich
famous people who are having babies with
people with whom they are not married it
is a bad social lesson you can have if
the idea is you can't afford to get
married then you're being like think
about your kid for a second wouldn't
want to lock that in wouldn't you want
your parents to actually be locked in to
raising the child but a parents matter
more than kids when it comes to
Hollywood how you feel about your own
life as an individual in Hollywood is
more important than how your child is
ensured a biological father and mother
raising them in Hollywood when asked if
she does anything differently when it
comes to parenting a girl compared to
boys
Hudson explained to the outlet that
having a daughter doesn't really change
my approach but there's definitely a
difference I think you just raise your
kids individually regardless like a
generalist approach we still don't know
what she's going to identify as well you
called her a she so that's a good
indicator right there he did this this
asinine utterly unscientific hard
differentiation between Oh what gender
she's going to be it's as though people
are picking a career we don't know
whether she wants to be an engineer or
whether she wants to be a painter and so
we're gonna raise her with
all available options in front of her we
don't know whether she's going to
identify as a girl or as a boy so we
leave all available options in front of
her well we have some early indicators
see when you're three months old it's
pretty fair to say that you don't know
whether she's gonna be an engineer or a
painter it is not quite fair to say you
don't know whether she's going to be a
girl or a boy when she's a girl Hudson
who is also moms whose sons Ryder 15 and
Bingham 7 from previous relationships
there it is right
great job parents and Kate huh we should
definitely go to her for parenting
advice she has a bunch of different kids
from a bunch of different men
I'm sure that's working out fantastic
for the kids and for there is no
psychological damage whatsoever from her
having shacked up with a bunch of
different dudes and had a bunch of
different kids buy a bunch of different
dudes cuz after all she's written in
Hollywood she said it's very different
from boys and it's really fun to
actually want to buy kids clothes with
the boys it was just like onesies
actually I did pretty good with the boys
but with her it's the whole other
ballgame there's some stuff I'm like I
can't do that to her because it's so
over the top so I love that she says
she's raising the kid genderless but
then she acknowledges she's buying
different stuff for the girl than she is
for the boy you know why cuz this is all
stupid this is all stupid trendy garbage
but this is the way that we parent now
in the 21st century
stupid trendy garbage now I do find
comfort in the fact that in the long run
of history all of this nonsense will be
wiped away because reality and biology
do win out when it comes to sex now all
of the people who are raising their kids
genderless the only real issue I have
with this is the damage done to the kid
it does damage kids when you
deliberately confuse them about their
sex kids are easily confused they don't
know things reinforcing basic truths
about the world is a useful thing and it
is far more psychologically damaging to
a child to tell them that you don't know
you don't know whether they're a boy or
a girl you're gonna have to take your
cues from your three-year-old honestly
it's more damaging to them in the long
run to repeat that sort of messaging
than it is to let them play outside by
themselves for a little while I'm sure
Kate Hudson has security full-time on
her kids but I highly but it seems like
security might want to protect her and
kids from her because this is this is
just silliness of the highest order okay
other things that I had one more thing
that I hate so the u.s. USC student
government is now trying to prevent
conservative speakers after I spoke
there last year last October I spoke
there in front of a couple thousand
students now the student government
senator Megan Lane and sent an aide ads
Anika Atma kinde have justified a new
bylaw amendment
hey it's a piece of amendment that
prevent conservatives from being invited
to campus they claim been Shapiro's
campus president incited undue violence
on the day of his presentation by the
way there was no violence the day of my
presentation none zero the proposed
amendment points out there is no process
for review or scrutiny of speakers
invited by student organizations the
amendment proposes speaker's be subject
to a special guest approval if the event
is ticketed expected to have an audience
of over 100 people if the student safety
is at risk or if substantial security is
required three reasons are given for
students petitioning speakers including
persons who have accepted endorsements
from hate organizations so they say that
the SPLC the Southern Poverty Law Center
a radical left group that labels
everything on the right hateful that
they should they should decide whether
somebody can speak at a campus they
recently had to settle with machine
nawaz and his Quilliam foundation for
falsely labeling the foundation is anti
Muslim extremists by the way the other
two grounds for petitioning speakers are
those who are publicly supported members
of hate organizations or those quote on
record as having publicly incited
supported or Express or explicitly
encouraged violence or harassment okay
well that's gonna be pretty fungible I
promise you folks on the left are going
to expand that to include anyone who
says hey boys boy and a girl is a girl
this is all in direct response to the
fact that we sold out in like an hour at
USC amazing how the left doesn't want to
it listen there's a big protest outside
it was all fine nothing happened but
that in itself was bad I was heard can't
have that well done leftist
demonstrating that you yourselves are
very much in favor of ideological
diversity and freedom of thought
alrighty well we will be back here a
little bit later today with your
two-hour live show this is why you
should subscribe go check it out right
now for $9.99 a month 99 bucks year you
get the tumbler as well go check that
out otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Adam SIA vets audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19